Your Honor that Eric Schmidt has agreed
to provide the keynote speech for
today's commencement this time I'd like
to invite him to do so ladies and
gentlemen dr. Eric Schmidt thank you
very much president Cohen I want to
start by congratulating all the all the
graduates and I want to especially
congratulate the parents and for the
parents remember that the students will
still need you and maybe now they'll
listen to you now that they've graduated
and when I when I see computers and
mobile phones and I want you to look and
think about everybody here has a mobile
phone with you and a camera I want you
to remember that everything you touch
was probably invented by computer
scientists that came from Carnegie
Mellon and this this startling and
surprising statistic is actually true
that in the 60s much of what we know in
modern computing was invented here by
giants in my field and I as a young
person roughly your age worked with
people who seem much older than me in
their 30s who had come through that
program who ultimately came to develop
the network's the workstations the
personal computers and the mobile
computing that we use today I was so
impressed by what Carnegie Mellon had
done for computer science that not only
did I become a trustee for a while but
Google now has one of its very top
ranked development centers here right on
campus where we have in many cases the
very best graduates and employees that
we could possibly get these are people
who do amazing things as part of our
underlying system and they occasionally
do interesting things as well that you
wouldn't expect they just released a
product called star draw you take your
mobile phone and turn it toward the sky
to tells you what the stars are doing
right how neat is that
why is Carnegie Mellon the place that is
so exceptional I think it's because the
culture is a culture of getting things
done it's not a purely theoretical
culture it's not a purely tactical
culture it's a culture that's about
accomplishing things for the world and
that is true regardless of the division
the department the college the Institute
that you are part of and that you
graduated from so so when I think about
you all I think about you as the
Facebook and the Google generation the
first generation that really grew up
with the internet when I grew up you
know we had Tang you had redbull we used
a programming language called basic you
all use Java we had VCRs that held a
half an hour of video that cost seven
hundred dollars and you all can upload
15 hours of video into YouTube every
minute we got our news from newspapers
you get yours from blogs and tweets and
for those of you don't know that's not
what you hear in zoos used to it in line
we stood in line to buy pong you stood
in line to buy wees we just didn't tell
anyone about our most embarrassing
moments you record them and post them to
facebook and youtube every day I am so
happy that my record of my miss
achievements is not around for posterity
i'm looking forward to yours being there
for many many years did you know that we
used mainframe computers with 300
megabytes of storage to go to the moon
six times you your iPods 120 gigabytes
have 500 times more just to get you to
your next class okay now you we thought
friend is a noun right you think it's a
verb we had phone booths anybody seen a
phone booth recently you have cell
phones we wore watches took pictures
with cameras navigating with maps and
listened to transistor radios you have a
cell phone
we thought that the marvels of computers
and technology again largely invented
here would change the world you agree
and we're both right why did you all go
to college to develop the kind of
analytical thinking skills confronting
the spin the crazy choices of
information that you'll have going
forward and then I would argue that you
have the opportunity to be the greatest
generation because right in front of you
now our tools that we never had that you
can take advantage of and and you sit in
your cell this guy must be mad and maybe
that's a little true but in front of us
you say oh you know the world's falling
apart we have this recession and so
forth I mean I did some research using
my favorite search engine of course and
the Great Depression spirits have
incredible innovations Rice Krispies
Twinkies and the beer can you would
never have gotten through college
without these three things so so good
things happen in recessions why is
ubiquitous information so important why
is it so important that we have access
to all the things it's a tremendous
equalizer in our lifetimes literally
certainly in yours if not line
essentially every human being in the
planet will have access to every piece
of information known on the planet this
is a remarkable achievement God knows
what these people will do and it's going
to be pretty amazing and information
serves as a check and balance on
politicians you know if you were a
dictator which you're not going to be
because you're fine graduates of
Carnegie Mellon the first thing you
would do is shut off all communications
to make sure that people couldn't take
advantage of knowledge and overthrow you
so what you do now with oppressive
regimes and people who do evil things is
you attack them with information you get
that information out there you use the
tools and technologies that all of us
have worked so hard on to make the world
a better place so what can we do with a
vastly more powerful web write the web
of information that comprise
is all of what we know you could
obviously have face-to-face meetings
with colleagues around the world but
more importantly now we can do dynamic
translation so we can translate between
languages so you could actually
understand if you're traveling in
Mongolia and you're on a motorcycle many
of you will do this right after you
graduate right to get away and you have
an accident you can actually have a
doctor consult with you around the world
and they can translate and provide you
the health care that you need these are
very real winds but most importantly you
can ask google the most important
questions that bother you like where are
my car keys after all you know computers
are really good at remembering some
things and in the New World much of this
again technology that was invented here
we know where everything can be we can
find them we can keep track of things we
can make your lives more more functional
but you can also ask questions like
what's the solution going to be global
warming where's the vaccine for flu
pandemics and you thought finals was
hard right think about the challenges
before you so what should you do now it
seems to me that you should you know
think about George Bernard Shaw who said
that all progress depends on
unreasonable man don't bother have a
plan at all all that stuff about plan
throw that out it seems to me that it's
all about opportunity and make your own
luck you study the most successful
people and they work hard and they take
advantage of opportunities that come
that they don't know are going to happen
to them you cannot plan innovation you
cannot plan invention all you can do is
try very hard to be in the right place
and be ready you know there's lots of
the pacemaker for example was invented
seventy years in one form or another
before it was applied I was applied to
this one one poor fella on 25 pacemakers
later he was still alive but the point
is he wouldn't have been at all had the
paceman could not have been invented you
never know and life is like that life is
a John lemming quote life is what
happens to you while you're busy making
other plans so live it with its fullness
and if you if you live your life and
forgo your plan you could also forgo
fear over the in some sense you've been
penalized for making mistakes
historically now you have to go out and
make them because mistakes allow you to
earn and to innovate and try new things
and that's a culture of innovation that
is going to create the next great
opportunities for all of you as you come
to run and rule the world and the rest
of us retire what should you do how
should you behave will do things in a
group don't do things by yourself groups
are stronger groups are faster none of
us as smart as all of us you can use
Twitter as a form of social intelligence
and its successors as well Watson and
Crick who discovered the structure of
DNA meditate University today they would
meet on Facebook and they would find
each other and then they would do this
amazing amazing things and they'd say to
each other what are you doing right now
Oh fighting the secret of life oh that
off to a pub LOL you know sort of it's
ok so i would tell you that amidst all
this change some truths endure
leadership and personality matter we saw
that from our student speaker
intelligence education and analytical
reasoning matter trust batters in a
networked world trust is your most
important currency which brings me to my
final question what is the meaning of
life correct question to ask at
university in a world where everything
is remembered and kept forever the world
you're graduating into you should live
for the future and the things that you
really care about don't live in the past
live in the future and what are those
things to figure this out you need to
actually turn off your computer I know
this is difficult you need to turn off
your phone you need to actually look at
the people who are near you and around
you and decide that it is humans who
ultimately are the most important thing
to us not the other aspects you'll find
out I hope what I believe very strongly
that people all around us of every race
color and viewpoint are fundamentally
want the same things they want a great
and safe world and they want prosperity
and peace among all of us you'll find
that curiosity enthusiasm and passion
are very contagious and I want you to
show that because you have it by virtue
of being here you'll find that nothing
the holding the hand of your grandchild
as he takes his first step you'll find
that a mindset in its own ways set in
its ways lockdown is a mind and a life
wasted don't do it you'll find that the
resilience in the human spirit is
amazing it's what got us through World
War One World War two and it will get us
through our current challenges just fine
you'll find today is the best chance you
have to start being unreasonable to
demand excellence to drive change to
make everything happen but when you do
speaking to the graduates always
remember to be nice to your parents and
true to your school thank you very much
and congratulations
you